pour les personnes en surpoids regardez
le sujet et on reçoit tout de suite
derrière nos invités
c'est le gros dose de la semaine qui
nous est offert par la truculante
Marianne James
la chanteuse latte et cette semaine dans
l'interview qu'elle a donné au magazine
Femme Actuelle un entretien fleuve et
sans filtre au cours duquel elle n'a pas
hésité à révéler son poids vous vous
rendez compte j'ai 60 ans je pèse 138 kg
et je suis en couverture mettez bien mon
poids j'y tiens et je n'ai aucun
problème à le dire c'est mon frère de
lance cela fait partie de moi l'ex
membre du jury de la Nouvelle Star
n'hésite plus désormais à se présenter
comme l'un des porte-drapeau des
personnes en surpoids aujourd'hui je
suis obèse je me réjouis de constater
qu'en l'assument j'aide les autres vous
n'imaginez pas le nombre de personnes
grosses de tout âge qui viennent me voir
pour me dire merci selon elle la
grossophobie touche encore énormément de
personnes dans le monde et pour la
combattre au mieux il faudrait carrément
instaurer des quotas je suis pour les
quotas qu'il y ait des lois pour
l'embauche des gros tout simplement un
combat qui pourrait paraître surprenant
pour celle qui n'a pas eu besoin de
quota pour s'imposer à la télévision
bref je suis pour les quotas pour les
personnes
comprenez-vous la déclaration de
Marianne James
[Applaudissements]
énorme sujet
pop demi finaliste et Diana Jones
Diana Jones un gold c'est à dire que
tout le monde te connait ça fait 6
millions de téléspectateurs pendant je
sais pas combien de prime et on t'a
connu et ce qui est très touchante tu
parles tout le temps enfin tu parles
tout le temps tu parles tout le temps
vrai
j'ai été j'ai été mince j'ai pris du
poids c'était dur j'ai gagné tant j'ai
fait ça tu dis les choses j'ai pas été
influenceuse tout ça t'es honnête et
c'est très très bien et c'est ce qu'il
faut alors c'est vraiment un pavé dans
la mars qui a dit effectivement
Marianne James je sais pas si vous le
comprenez chez vous donc voilà ce
qu'elle a dit effectivement elle a dit
que aujourd'hui elle pèse 138 kg
je 60 ans je pèse 138 kg je suis en
couverture je suis tellement fier
mettez-moi bien mon poids j'y tiens je
n'ai aucun problème à le dire le surpoid
engendre un déficit d'image les gros ont
un quotidien extrêmement compliqué tant
dans leur vie personnelle que
professionnelle la grosse grosse
beaucoup de mal 45% des personnes en
situation d'obésité sont discriminées au
travail on les reçoit pas sur les
plateaux télé on ne leur donne aucune
chance aujourd'hui en gros si tu es
jolie et sans talent tu as plus de
chance que si tu es fort on va dire mais
avec du talent alors déjà la première
peut-être personne à qui j'aimerais
parler bah c'est olympique salut Olympe
parce que Olympe effectivement tu as
fait The Voice tu allais en demi-finale
finale pardon final tu as perdu en
finale et face à des paniers et tout ça
c'est dire le niveau que tu as et
effectivement tu t'es un peu lâché
derrière et tu dis je cherche ta fiche
depuis 1h et tu dis euh
mais il y a pas de souci
Alex
dernière avertissement
et par écrit je suis là
pas possible de chaque saboter les gens
comme ça pardon là
donc candidats et vraiment tu as déclaré
après coup tout ce que tu avais vécu ce
qu'on t'a dit là-bas grosso modo et
pourtant à l'époque tu faisais 68 kg tu
dis c'est ça alors en fait c'était pas
pendant The Voice c'était après après
l'émission bah en fait on est parti en
tournée avec Louane avec plein de monde
et on a appris tous un peu de poids je
pense que je devais faire aller 74 75 kg
à l'époque et là en fait mon équipe
artistique m'a dit ben on peut plus te
mettre en télé tu es trop gros on est
obligé de te cacher derrière un piano
alors moi déjà ça m'a blessé parce que
le piano pour moi c'était pas un objet
de décoration c'était mon instrument
avec lequel bah voilà je m'exprimais et
du coup bah là en fait c'était en mode
on s'en fout que tu puisses bien chanter
ou jouer du piano nous tout ce qu'on
veut en fait c'est que tu sois beau et
mince parce que d'accéder mais là
franchement moi je me trouve pas gros là
dessus
et est-ce que je peux te poser une
question
en fait définition il y a pas de
définition vous savez quand elle est
enterré les gens savent tout ils disent
toujours vous savez les gens pensent que
l'aménageur pense que alors qu'ils y
connaissent rien ils sont sur la caméra
moi déjà j'ai une question peut-être un
peu perso à partir de quel moment
pourquoi tu t'es mis à prendre du poids
tu sais un petit peu en fait je me suis
mis à prendre du poids parce que à
chaque fois on disait faut que tu en
perdre donc du coup je me concentrer
plus sur la musique je me concentrer sur
mon poids et moi j'ai toujours eu une
tendance à apprendre du poids facilement
en perdre rapidement donc je perdais
beaucoup de poids mais en fait je
n'arrivais pas à tenir le rythme donc je
reprenais plus de kilos que j'avais
perdu je refaisais un régime et j'en
prenais encore plus et au final j'en ai
pris 25 alors que ben voilà à la base si
j'avais gardé mon régime alimentaire et
voilà je j'aurais peut-être un peu
grossi mais pas autant oui ben non moi
j'ai une question parce que tout à
l'heure on dit gros gros les gros mais
est-ce que gros ça peut être et c'est
grossophobe de dire quelqu'un cette
personne est grosse c'est un gros
moi mais je trouve que le terme il est
même moi je suis mal à l'aise de le dire
bonjour vous êtes gros enfin ça me
dérange
pas moi je pense que ça se dit ça dépend
de l'intention l'intention est très très
importante
donc The Voice The Voice 2015 chanteuse
incroyable et effectivement dans The
Voice bah forcément comme les gens n'ont
rien d'autre à faire quelques méchant
parce que comme il n'existe pas leur vie
il faut bien qu'ils abîme cette des
autres
ça commence à partir avec des choses
très méchants c'est dans The Voice que
j'ai découvert que j'étais gros en fait
vous étiez heureux avant ah mais je suis
aussi heureusement
tout va bien pour moi
ça vous a fait mal en fait c'est pas que
ça m'a fait mal c'est que ça m'a surpris
je me suis dit parce que les réseaux
sociaux tout le monde a accès à ce qu'on
dit quand on a un compte public etc et
je me suis dit quelle est cette personne
qui se fout la honte de dire un truc
comme ça le premier commentaire je passe
à la télé le premier commentaire Twitter
c'est quand je te vois j'ai envie de
vomir ce à quoi j'ai répondu
en 2020 parce que après quand on a
beaucoup de gens qui nous suivent on
essaie de pas passer des gens même
méchants sous le bus du
cyber-harcèlement parce que c'est pas
parce qu'on nous le fait et qu'on doit
le faire mais c'est à partir de là où je
me suis dit ah oui c'est vrai ah oui
c'est vrai pour les gens je suis grosse
mais pour moi je suis pas grosse c'est
que je suis le niveau zéro il y a plus
gros que moi et plus mince que moi
est-ce que derrière The Voice en
revanche vous avez senti que les maisons
de disques en gros bah faire un disque
avec une fille qui chante bien mais
voilà quoi qu'on mettra pas trop trop
sur les petits plateaux de télé pour
exciter les petits garçons ou les
petites jeunes filles c'était que je te
dise la vérité Mathieu je préfère
ça ne s'est pas bien passé du tout
dis-moi pourquoi c'est des gens qui
pourtant m'ont vu dans The Voice j'ai
signé avec le label de mes rêves tous
mes toutes mes idoles d'adolescentes
muse etc avait signé sur ce label et
donc quand on m'a dit ben il va te
signer je
dis de mon rêve éveillé bien sûr
et donc ils étaient un peu au courant
que j'étais grosse et au fur et à mesure
ils sont dit bon on va faire un clip etc
j'ai tourné un clip ça s'est très bien
passé ils sont venus sur le tournage là
là tu es tellement belle ah tellement de
sensualité machin nanana c'était un clip
simple mais je les aime tous sur une
chanson sensuelle etc
et c'était en 2016 et
donc on termine le clip le fibres monte
à la direction je reçois un appel genre
il faut absolument qu'on parle il y a un
problème avec le clip et en fait il
s'est avéré que ces gens devant moi
m'ont dit c'est gênant de te voir comme
ça faut savoir que je suis en body
entouré de tissu noir on peut pas je
suis pas enfin
j'y vais même pas en mode à la isote
c'est-à-dire que on voit un petit peu de
boobies mais c'est tout et
mais vraiment il me regarde dans c'est
très gênant Mathieu non on peut pas
sortir ça vraiment pour ton image nous
on a été hyper choqué limite il me
disait que c'était dégoûtant c'était
trop sexy c'est ça
fait beaucoup trop quoi c'était trop
c'était pas ça le problème et puis en
plus sur une chanson qui s'appelle je
les aime tous au bout d'un vous savez
que les grosses aussi ont une sexualité
ce n'est pas une avant de fiction en
fait c'est une c'est une vraie chanson
populaire
du coup on va pas sortir le clip je suis
mais moi j'ai mis 2000 euros dans le
bouzin ils avaient mis 7000 balles ah
bah oui mais hétéro ça alors ils l'ont
pas dit comme ça parce que peut-être
plus poliment mais est-ce que tu
pourrais perdre un petit peu de poids
non ils me l'ont pas dit ils m'ont juste
dit bon il y aura pas de clip d'accord
sachant que quand tu es artiste
indépendant ou même quand tu es dans un
label Youtube c'est le premier moteur de
recherche aujourd'hui musicale et quand
on te dit il y aura pas de clip c'est ta
musique n'existera pas sur le plus gros
moteur de recherche et ma question je
vais t'expliquer pourquoi les quotas
pour en parler tout à l'heure pardon je
suis désolé pour les plus âgés qui nous
regardent quand je parle Ginette Reno
c'est une énorme star au Canada c'est la
Céline Dion elle a une voix incroyable
Mathieu canadienne et René lui dit je
vais faire de toi une start à tenevois
gigantesque mais elle est forte et elle
dit je ne veux pas perdre du poids et
lui ai dit je ne m'occuperai pas de toi
parce qu'on ne fera pas de carrière
internationale avec le poids que tu as
et elle est restée au Canada et il a
pris Céline à qui leur fait les dents
les cheveux tout tout tout le cerveau et
je plaisante humour humour humour
vraiment humour c'est méchant et voilà
et pour te dire que ces problèmes là ne
sont absolument pas nouveau et c'est
vrai que du coup est-ce que Marianne
James a pas mis un pavé dans la mare
est-ce que toi tu serais pour qu'il y a
un quota dans les entreprises moi j'ai
un problème j'ai un problème de base
avec la discrimination positive parce
que si on doit faire de la
discrimination positive c'est en
réaction à de la discrimination négative
elle a raison mais vraiment c'est à dire
que si on se met à parler de
discrimination positive et de dire il
faudrait qu'il y ait des quotas ça veut
dire que naturellement les gens
n'embauchent pas des groupes parce
qu'ils sont gros ok alors tu dis la
vérité si t'en mets pas bah moi j'ai une
société il y a pas d'handicapé dans ma
société je te dis la vérité tu regardes
la télévision 96% des animateurs sont
blancs
moi je pense que il faut pouvoir
diversifier aussi c'est à dire que créer
des ma chérie mais tu crois que j'ai
envie de pas vivre dans un monde de
bisounours tu as vu le vrai monde comme
on n'a pas envie d'y vivre laisse moi
dans ma foi en fait
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu penses toi des quotas
même professionnellement parce que toi
tu as tu as vécu toi moi j'ai vécu
j'étais une ancienne bimbo sexy bon moi
j'ai on m'a pris parce que j'étais sexy
hein on n'est pas venu me chercher
aujourd'hui en mode phoque donc
forcément on m'a pris du tout là bébé
on ne peut pas faire des couvertures
aujourd'hui en maillot de bain on est
d'accord donc voilà donc ce que je
rejoins la dame de que vous avez tout à
l'heure
c'est leur domaine Mathilde c'est leur
donner de l'importance dans le sens où
on acquise qu'ils veulent on n'a pas dit
on va mettre un noir là un arabe là un
gros là un mec là un handicapé non on
n'a pas dit ça on met les gens qui sont
compétents pour le les postes qui qui
sont est-ce que tu as marqué quelque
chose dans les entreprises tu as
toujours en général un mec qui a un
fauteuil roulant qui dit vous savez j'ai
fait ces entreprises avant je suis sûr
diplômé personne m'a pris toi le patron
tu dis oh c'est dégueulasse oh les con
il est con
je ne peux pas moi non plus ça marche
comme ça oui mais ça dépend où parce
qu'aux États-Unis ça marche pas comme ça
c'est si elle veut faire une défilé de
lingerie qu'on la prend pas ou comprend
pas c'est normal parce qu'on
toi et moi on doit mettre des slips
quand même aussi oui mais ce que je veux
dire
par là en tant que mannequin on va pas
se leurrer une question en tant comédien
ou chanteur c'est des compétences ça n'a
rien à voir avec le physique voilà
est-ce que Olympe tu penses que ta
carrière est très belle tu étais connu
de tout le monde ton nom est connu de
tout le monde et tu chantes mais est-ce
que tu penses qu'elle aurait été
peut-être différente si tu avais été
plus mince bah alors pour tout vous dire
en fait moi mon équipe à l'époque quand
je pouvais plus passer sur les télés
parce que c'est trop gros et bah ils
m'ont demandé si je voulais pas perdre
du poids et pourquoi pas faire une
opération de chirurgie donc j'ai fait
une liposuccion qui voilà j'ai été
en le ventre l'intérieur des cuisses les
cuisses le bas du dos j'ai pratiquement
pas et du coup j'ai été j'avais
l'impression d'être un une personne âgée
de 118 ans tellement je me sentais mal
après des Bleus partout etc et en fait
ben elle se déboque là vraiment là je
vois pas ce que j'aurais pu perdre de
plus peut-être un bout d'os ou en fait
ça n'a pas suffi donc je me dis il y a
un moment ça suffit jamais
voilà moi ce que j'ai pardon
mais c'était pour casser un peu
l'ambiance donc pardon
par des meilleurs ambianceurs qui vont
faire le débat à un moment donné il y a
des gens qui on parle de beaucoup de
choses entreprise handicapées etc c'est
autre chose là on fait limiter de
spectacle il y a des gens qui sont
derrière nous qui achètent des disques
qui regardent la télé pourquoi les gens
sont beaux à la télé moi j'ai passé ma
vie professionnelle avec le petit gros
parce qu'elle bataille et tous les ans
regardez les saisons il y a que la
vérité qui compte elle passe sur Youtube
vous allez voir que je passe de ça à ça
et tous les étés je faisais régime et
pour septembre je revenais un peu plus
beau gosse entre guillemets pourquoi je
dis beau gosse parce que j'étais moins
gros tout simplement et ma femme me le
disait mon accompagnement me disait et
c'est presque normal quoi on fait des
métiers d'images
plaignez vous de savoir pourquoi le
public pas les dirigeants de chaîne pas
les producteurs ceux qui sont derrière
nous ce soir là et ben ils regardent des
gens qui sont beaux et des gens mais
alors
que si tu as du talent tu n'as pas le
droit de faire un métier d'image mais
absolument pas est-ce que tu viens de
dire plein de gros pour réussir
la chanson
mais arrêtez de deux exceptions je pense
qu'il faut que tu fasses confiance au
public le public est infiniment moins
con que ça
sauf que tu en connais beaucoup des gens
qui sont forts en France et qui ont fait
une grande carrière en France
au public
mais j'ai fait ma mère vraiment
papa papa Mathilde j'ai fait The Voice
The Voice j'ai fait The Voice parce que
ça s'appelait pas the body the Voice il
y avait pas à me demander d'être chose
que une voie raison et en fait moi ce
que j'ai gardé de The Voice c'est pas
mon contrat de disque que j'ai eu après
c'est pas mon manager eux ils sont
taillés mais il y a des gens qui me
suivent encore aujourd'hui qui
soutiennent mon travail qui achète mes
singles qui m'écoutent toujours et qui
m'ont découvert dans The Voice le seul
truc qui est resté justement c'est le
public parce que le public est beaucoup
moins con qu'on ne le pense et je pense
qu'il faudrait qu'on lui demande
[Applaudissements]
ont toujours refusé de maigrir parce
qu'on exigeait sa belle elle a décidé un
jour de maigrir mais elle l'a voulu mais
elle est quand même un tout petit peu
influencée par l'état d'esprit du milieu
le public est parfois aussi de mauvaise
foi et changeante et par exemple au
cinéma notamment parce que c'est mon
boulot de suivre tous ces gens-là tous
ceux que vous voyez mince et tout ils
ont subi souvent ce que tu dis des
anneaux gastriques des trucs comme ça
qui n'en finit par pas marcher et qui
font le yoyo
c'est très souvent des encombrants
engendre des problèmes de santé
bien sûr et aussi dire que faut pas être
hypocrite dans une entreprise si on
bouge pas un gros c'est souvent si on se
dit il a même pas la montée de maigrir
et ça sera pas winner
écoutez vous Florian
ça fait 20 ans que je travaille j'ai
toujours bossé avec des aussi et je vais
dire quelque chose qui va dans le sens
de Laurent c'est à dire que Marianne
James je l'ai interviewé il y a un an
c'était pour closer et quand je lui ai
demandé si elle était heureuse avec son
poids elle m'a répondu un truc qui m'a
un peu mis mal à l'aise elle m'a dit bah
tu comprends j'ai pas envie de maigrir
parce que si je maigris mon public qui
est une sorte de communauté ne va plus
me reconnaître et ne va plus forcément
typiquement est-ce que est-ce que il y a
il y en a pas qui ont aussi tendance à
signer du bois alors ça c'est ça que je
veux dire je c'est vrai parce que du
coup quand j'ai fait mon gros régime il
y a des fans qui m'ont dit maigris pas
trop ma puce reconnaître et en fait je
me suis dit mais c'est chaud là parce
que toi tu es pour les quotas non moi en
fait moi le quota c'était non ça me
dérange le quota parce que ça veut dire
que si tu as la télé dans telle émission
c'est parce qu'il y a un quota ça veut
dire qu'il fallait une grosse don ou un
gros non on te met là et c'est pas
forcément parce que tu mérites il y a
plein d'autres gros de grosses qui qui
mériteraient d'être à cette place en
fait toi tu es plus heureuse aujourd'hui
là comme ça ou quoi tu étais bimbo ah
non quand j'étais bimbo je suis pas
heureuse
fâché avec eux mais par contre je suis
heureuse dans le sens où on m'emmerde on
ne drague pas on me regarde pas comme un
comme un steak on regarde dans les yeux
donc ça change mais j'ai une question à
te poser si tu prends 40 kilos série il
te remet la saison prochaine ou pas mais
vraiment je vais te dire je pense que
c'est pas pareil pour les garçons mais
en revanche je vais te dire quelque
chose non c'est pourquoi
tu prends vraiment le super pardon je
sais pas pour défendre le patron
qui choisit pas les gens sur le casting
physique gros
maintenant quelque chose le premier
casting que j'ai passé c'était à Canal+
en 2004 pour nous ne sommes pas des
anges il y a mytena biraba on est 40 à
passer je passe c'est mon casting c'est
sur la finance et un moment donné elle
me dit est-ce que tu as des poils je dis
pas eu tout je suis un berbe elle me dit
montre-le moi j'enlève mon t-shirt
j'étais musclé j'ai fait cette séquence
j'ai été engagé oui je suis pas
complètement con au début elle m'a pas
engagé parce qu'on avait parlé 10
minutes finances je l'avais engagé sur
ma gueule au départ je te le dis parce
qu'il y a pas là par rapport à Siri
c'est que dans si tu prends 40 kg ton
talent il est tel quel donc ça change
rien tu sais 40 kg en plus ou moins bien
sûr que ça on est d'accord sur change
rien sauf que ça change de fait que
aujourd'hui effectivement à l'antenne et
on est tous pareils c'est ce que tu
disais je vais vous donner un truc vous
savez ce qu'on fait en télé si vous le
savez pas quand on met un animateur ou
quand on met des gens derrière le public
pardon pas ici on a pas le temps petite
chaîne mais derrière le public on place
systématiquement des baux ou des belles
derrière l'animateur Jordanie au
Reichmann tu as trois bombasses et tu
auras jamais trois boudins pardon de te
le dire c'est comme ça on met des belles
mais c'est vrai que Laurent il y a des
belles endroit
prochainement maigri alors qu'il n'avait
maigri que parce que le médecin lui dit
vous êtes en état d'obésité dangereuse
en revanche toi tu as un talent fou
alors toi ou pas poire ou pas point
on monte en haut bah j'ai créé mon lapin
sur les plateformes de streaming j'ai
sorti un album dans les magasins si je
savais c'est mon dernier single et puis
là je sors un titre tous les mois sur
Spotify jusqu'à l'arrivée de mon
prochain album au mois d'octobre et moi
je j'ai créé un label pour produire
d'autres talents aussi qui selon leur
place qui méritent il y a des gros des
moins gros et tout quand on est quand on
est soi-même ça fait toujours par payer
et toi tu fais quoi mon chou ben moi je
travaille toujours à Marseille
je travaille aussi et j'ai des rentes
mais je travaille toujours à Marseille
tout le temps encore oui
des fois on me dit que j'ai grossi non
c'est déjà aujourd'hui
il me voit sur les réseaux je fais pas
mal de contenu ou j'interagis avec eux
mais surtout il m'écoutent j'ai sorti
quelques singles ils sont disponibles
sur toutes les plateformes et là je
prépare un deuxième album moi je te
connaissais pas je te trouve formidable
je suis ravi de t'avoir rencontré